martin achète une toile solaire et aux
systèmes de filtration pour ces piscines
coût total avec les taxes 3000 dollars
quelque peu plus tard un livreur sont à
la porte
il lui remet une grosse boîte céline
martin singh le bordereau de livraison
sans vérifier le contenu de l'envoi mais
quand elle ouvre la boîte mauvaises
surprises
il n'y a pas de système de filtration
contacter le commerçant il refuse de lui
un donneur non proteste
elle a quand même payer ce système dit
de rien à faire le vendeur est
catégorique c'est non
qui a raison la signature du bordereau
de livraison par martin est loin d'être
un geste banal ce que cette signature
veux dire c'est qu'elle admet qu'elle a
bien reçu sa marchandise
c'est donc à elle de prouver qu'elle n'a
pas reçu le fameux système de filtration
quant aux commerçants il n'est pas tenu
de lui en remettre un nouveau temps que
cette démonstration ne lui a pas été
fait
le fin mot de l'histoire ouvrez vos
boîtes d'abord signer ensuite